eu vou buscar é tentar demonstrar pra
vocês como a carne orgânica pode mudar o
mundo e bem a minha infância a respeito
dessas imagens é só olhar da minha
janela
eu achei bonito trazer isso para me
distrair
através de me distrair não consigo me
concentrar e são beija flor pra quem não
sabe e na minha infância eu vivia muito
no partido tal era uma pessoa muito
tímida e por causa disso eu desenvolvi
muita relação com os animais e plantas e
comecei primeiro com animais domésticos
mas depois fui ganhando todas as aranhas
e com animais selvagens acontecer uma
coisa muito interessante e eu fui sempre
estudando desde pequenininho odontologia
que eu achava de livros para tentar
entender mais me relacionar melhor
conhece meus sonhos de vida não todos
relacionados com animais e tem muitos
animais e com o passar do tempo é eu
tive sempre muita sorte e eu fui
entendendo que alguns vários animais
estavam em risco e comecei a me
preocupar com essas coisas e eu tive só
de um amigo do da minhas irmãs mais
velhas que estava na faculdade
participou da criação da primeira
entidade ecológica brasileira agapan
e aí ele se lembrou de mim fui lá no
colégio está no primeiro grau a inglesa
descobriu um negócio pra te levar na
reunião nos cara lá vai gostar
aí fomos fui lá na reunião
claro que eu era um mascote era um guri
ele tal ouvir aquele troço será celulose
para cá células palavra estranha da
cidade o cheiro os monstros destruído
por pedreira não será sequer saiu no
final tinha um tradicional chopinho lutz
adorava entrevista ainda mais
pessoas que estavam ali chegando né e aí
que taxou o leitão no rolete
eu fiquei um pouco frustrado ele como
assim
de modo que é só tapurah com este
negócio a luta e eu penso que a ecologia
que deu eu acho que a ecologia do nosso
revolucionário e vai mudar a forma de
viver das pessoas me olhando assim que
tu acha esse ano eu acho que o convite
ele sim tu acha que isso vai acontecer
como magia timão vai demorar tempo
se nós não proteger a natureza até lá
não vamos ter natureza quando as pessoas
se derem conta do valor dela e aí ele me
ganhou nessa tal transformou um guri
metido em mais um na luta ea luta
permeou a minha vida eu fui o segundo
grau
quando cheguei na faculdade eu já era um
ambientalista velho né
e tudo que eu fiz tudo que eu estudei
iam a minha meta até pelo convívio da
agapan fui me dando conta do nível de
complexidade e me apaixonei pela
complexidade eu já tinha uma paixão pela
ecologia comecei a ver as questões
sociais e outras
e foi isso que eu tentei entender e eu
tentei na universidade já entrei
determinado a fazer um curso generalista
estudar aquilo que eu queria cada coisa
em cada curso e foi isso que eu fiz e e
vem fazendo ainda não cheguei em lugar
nenhum ela mas já tô já tem um monte de
coisinhas
então o que aconteceu é eu me dei conta
que a primeira coisa que foi nosso alvo
de uma nova forma de viver ea nova forma
de viver um novo tipo de desenvolvimento
e esse desenvolvimento
brigamos pelo nome ou não mas é o
desenvolvimento sustentável o
desenvolvimento sustentável tem quatro
características principais da minha
forma de ver o ambiental que é a
característica fútil desenvolvimento
sustentável saiu exclusivamente da luta
ambiental do fato que nós estamos
destruindo o planeta e que não é mais
sustentável para as outras gerações
então ambiental está muito ligado à
contaminação do planeta porque a gente
acha que corta árvore é um problema é um
problema mas é muito pior
lugares que a gente nem chegou
já estão doentes contaminados nós
estamos contaminando com químicos
sintéticos que nós criamos e não
existiam em toda a evolução da espécie
portanto eles causam um monte de erros e
confusões na natureza
nós estamos contaminando agora
recentemente com a pior todos
contaminações contaminação genética onde
a gente larga organismos que não
existindo evolução das espécies
transgénicas mistura de material
genético de um organismo diferentes
larga na natureza e eles cruzam porque
tem um pólo e eles têm a eles são
férteis
então eles estão contaminando uma forma
muito preocupante e isso está permeando
então a gente vê ilhas de lixo no oceano
ninguém chegou lá numa ilha ainda já é
um depósito de lixo
depois da parte ambiental existe a parte
econômica e economicamente viável o
desenvolvimento tem que ser bom eu acho
que a viabilidade mais estrutural do
planeta ea fome na então tem que ter um
desenvolvimento que de quanto ela fome
que a coisa mais essencial nós não
vivemos sem água e sem a água é a
contaminação de água tem está sendo
contaminada ea fome
a fome é a segurança alimentar não é
qualquer comida
nós precisamos comida de qualidade em
seu lugar
é a justiça social porque não é possível
que um planeta rico como o nosso
as pessoas vivam sem ter uma remuneração
justa para viver não é decente as
pessoas não estão nem trabalhar
bastava vivem têm direito de comer todos
viveram na história até a gente criar
esse mundo moderno e se alimentavam
então é importantíssimo que haja mas o
quarto aspecto que é o que mais me
apaixona tão importante quanto ambiental
é o do desenvolvimento centavo é o
respeito cultural porque tão importante
por duas razões pra mim
a cultura é nada mais do que expressão
do meio ambiente
o ser humano é muito arrogante ele acha
que queria muito
na verdade ele é forçado a criar ea
cultura é a expressão da experiência
humana naquele local cada ecossistema no
mundo é diferente cada cultura é também
porque pra viver naquele lugar
um homem teve que aprender a humanidade
aprender coisas diferentes rubber
diferente falar diferente pelo clima
viver de forma diferente construir casas
diferentes então a cultura humana é uma
grande expressão do meio ambiente
por outro lado é através da cultura da
destruição cultural que se manipulam os
povos
a coisa mais antiga nas guerras era
destruir atacar a cultura da pessoa
porque ela fica desestruturada fica mal
de auto-imagem perde seus conceitos para
os seus valores ea itu domina ele faz
com ele o que quer
então a cultura é também a força dos
pólos
a primeira coisa a estética a escada
povo cada ecossistema de uma estética
ora se todo mundo demoras na na praia
sonhasse com o campo a serra não é a
estética é estética do que conhece as
proporções daquela população humana as
cores daquela população os gostos
sabores então a estética é muito
importante ea beleza pra mim
a beleza pra mim é expressão da
felicidade porque cá entre nós pessoas
que brilham os olhos estão felizes
sempre são lindas sempre são lindas
por outro lado uma pessoa endividada o
kumar diarreia não consegue jogar bonito
já venho já viu alguém quer era
impossível porque ela é a expressão do
da vivenda hora
nós estamos fazendo uma coisa nós temos
uma sociedade nós construímos um mundo
queiramos ou não todos nós e parceria
que todos nós somos coniventes mesmo nós
construirmos um mundo de crianças
tristes de adultos dopados de água cada
vez mais contaminada de contaminações
agora até genéticas e nós estamos
vivendo isso um mundo triste um mundo
que está
todos nós sentimos de todos nós estamos
buscando uma forma de modificar isso aí
bem este mundo que é uma obra conjunta
eu não me eximo dela porque eu estou
aqui também através das minhas ações
tô reafirmando esse mundo quando me
descuido o eu tou modificando quando
estou a tempo mas esse mundo tem uma
cura ea cura no desenvolvimento
sustentável mais estrutural que eu acho
é agroecologia porque o desenvolvimento
estruturado sustentável requer uma
agricultura em harmonia com a natureza
a agroecologia uma agricultura que busca
aprender com a natureza se alimentar
dela entender os processos não intervir
de forma artificial mas buscar essa
compreensão e através disso ele produz
produtos naturais alimento orgânico é o
alimento não contaminado com a
ignorância humana mas baseado na
inteligência da natureza a na natureza o
equilíbrio planetário são conjuntos de
espécie em cada ecossistema um conjunto
para cada ambiente um conjunto diferente
que será moleza que se equilibra que
todas as peças são importantes não
existe praga na natureza não hesitou
todos têm função o que a gente chama de
praga aqui às vezes são plantas
primárias que quando a uma
desertificação elas vão recriar o solo
ou são plantas ou são insetos que comem
as plantas doentes para limpar natureza
e é o que faz inclusive as doenças
humanas
ninguém adoece pessoal a gente se faz
doente
as doenças são indicadores de que a
pessoa não está bem
pessoas saudáveis não adoecem a gente
mudou esse conceito em algum lugar e
perdeu o fio da meada
nós precisamos recuperar isso
agroecologia então ela é um aprendizado
constante ela aponta para um mundo mais
colorido mais humano mais conectado do
que esse mundo desconectado de crianças
com défice de atenção e eu tenho que do
pai delas com ritalina ou adultos
consolidam com uns tristeza com o
sofrimento que eu tenho que do país com
antidepressivos
esse mundo reconectado ele traz de novo
para nós do que nós que nós somos
e aí que eu quero chegar
bom aí tem a alimentação alimentação é a
forma mais forte que nós temos de
relacionamento que essa nós vamos romper
menos parcialmente estamos comendo muita
porcaria especial à alimentação tem uma
história importante você se lembra dos
anjos aquele cara tal foi o passeio tal
jogar
caiu o avião nos andes aí o avião de
vocês
tinha duas pessoas que morreram na queda
e vocês estão com fome canibalismo uma
parte canibalismo é uma mera definição
cultural é cara e aí vocês precisam
comer ou morre
e aí tinha um cara que estava doente há
muito tempo e uti e estava viajando para
fazer uma operação foi com soro e tudo
ali de um cara ocorreu infelizmente
faleceu e tinha um atleta que estava
indo jogar uma pessoa jovem tal que
também morreu
e aí eu pergunto a você as precisando se
alimentar com a carne de quem você se
alimentariam todo mundo vai dizer que o
atleta não é verdade porque quando eu
levo para casa de vocês
uma galinha caipira todo mundo reclama
que tem cheiro que é duro de mastigar e
etc
vocês viram na verdade dizer que ou se
alimentar do atleta mas vocês venham com
o meu pessoal da uti
vocês iam comer a carne branquinha
descolorido e bem molinha igualzinho às
galinhas linhas de campo de concentração
de vocês comem ser criada sobre o
sofrimento abaixo de remédios totalmente
contaminado com todo tipo de produto que
nem está aquela pessoa não teria são
opções a gente faz diariamente mas aí
eles a isso tem cheiro vida tem cheiro
alimentos saudáveis têm cheiro e nós
temos esse ano a despeito de alguns não
sabendo de tudo bem como mas olha só que
é importante o que eu disse que planejar
não quero uma boa porque sempre planeja
da deixou tocar coisas em 4 distrai
vocês
mas aqui beleza é e aí a mas então
pessoal
a carne orgânica nada mais é do que uma
expressão da agroecologia se eu faço uma
natureza completa os ecossistemas têm
animais
esses animais são indispensáveis por
exemplo pampa hoje o pampa nosso bioma
importantes na metade sul do estado do
rio grande do sul a argentina uruguai e
paraguai
muito bem o pampa hoje sem os ruminantes
embora exóticos foram introduzidos na
pelos juízes governos
ouvimos né ele não se mantém mais o
bioma porque os herbívoros naturais se
foram
então esses árbitros hoje são
necessários para manter o ecossistema é
necessário produção animal e o que o
animal está a encantar as pessoas às
vezes tem gente que não come animal
eu respeito muito a pessoa não gosto
alguns não não querem comer porque não
querem matar outros por outras razões
porque por exemplo a comida a carne ela
dá um certo grau de agressividade
existem pesquisas mostrando isso hora e
nós não precisamos de agressividade em
alguns momentos da vida
quer dizer eu conheço pessoas
vegetarianas que em alguns momentos como
em casa porque eles sabem equilibrar o
alimento é uma oportunidade gigantesca
que a gente tem o que é carne orgânica a
carne orgânica
eu prometi que ia mudar o mundo não é
com ela a carne orgânica é fruto de um
animal que foi tratado com remédios
naturais homeopatia e fitoterapia que
foi alimentado com alimentos orgânicos
ou seja alimentos criados só com coisas
naturais plantados pastagem milho o que
for de coisas naturais e terceiro lugar
viveu com dignidade uma coisa que a
gente quase não esqueçamos entre nós
imagina com os animais viver com
dignidade pode brincar pode passear por
tomar sol teve sombra para se deitar
quando precisou água limpa e seta
condições de vida e as pessoas têm pena
para animais a gente tinha que ter pena
de fazer os animais sofrerem como nós
fazemos hoje porque a vida é o que
interessa não a morte todos nós vamos
morrer não estamos preocupados com isso
nós temos que nos preocupar com a nossa
remuneração com a nossa qualidade de
vida enquanto vivos
a carne orgânica pra fazer essa
alimentação ela precisa de todo um
contexto natural por isso o amor do
mundo ela muda a nossa concepção de às
vezes a gente quer por exemplo que os
animais se comportam como humanos
a gente não respeita a cultura deles
porque eles têm a cultura deles
ele tem um comportamento e as
necessidades deles então o ser humano
negava os animais hoje ele trata os
animais como humanos e os vegetais não
tem direito vegetal não sente vegetal
são todos seres vivos
olindo da alimentação é que nós sorvemos
vidas e transformamos as vidas dos
outros em nossa vida nós construímos
diariamente o nosso corpo através da
vida dos outros
a energia dos jogos a qualidade de vida
dos outros
passa a ser a nossa qualidade de vida os
índios já sabia eles nunca comiam é
covarde eles vão comer porque não
queriam ficar assim
eles sabiam que o alimento que faz
alimentos felizes com boa qualidade de
vida fazem é através da cadeia vida que
a expressão do sagrado maior nós
perdemos a noção do sagrado
o sagrado do alimento é as vidas que
estão ali milhares de fetos de arroz
milhares de folhas de plantinhas animais
que estão ali doando a vida para
continuar como nós daremos um dia
desconectado como nós estamos é tristeza
é doença é ódio é egoísmo reconexão que
é o que a gente está propondo através
dos movimentos tentado
a arte de parar no momento certo
reconexão é ao contrário é alegria e
saúde é amor e é compaixão que é
admiração pelos direitos dos outros
serem diferentes não só humanos animais
plantas encarar e deixar de ser cínico
encarar a vida como ela é
são vidas que a gente vive seifando pra
dar uns aos outros
obrigado